Markiplier: Hello everybody!
My name is Markiplier
And I'm joined once again by Team Edge
Ryan and Matt of course
And we're gonna be doing
'The drunk water balloon go through
this giant bouncy castle that we rented
for this particular video' -challenge
Matthias: Look! Look!
Markiplier: We literally rented a giant bouncy castle
Just cause we could
And we're going to do a video with it
Matthias: Why not?
Mark: We have drunk goggles, their alcohol is-
We have drunk goggles and if you've
ever had a these on they make it really hard to see
So what we're going to be doing is each team member
individually is going through with these
while the other guys are gonna be
pelting us with water balloons
and our
time is timed and then added to our
team's time and then the team time
between the two teams is gonna be compared
between the team time between teams
Got it?
Cool
Alright
Ryan: The team time.. Whoever has less.
Mark: Yeah who ever has less time
Bryan: So easy quick.
Mark: Oh shit!
Bryan: You're facing the wrong way.
Mark: No I'm not!
3... 2... 1...Go! (Whistle)
Off Camera: You missed!
Mark: Oww [Strange grunting noises]
Off Camera: You all missed!
*Random noises from Markimoo*
Off Camera: Right in the face!
*Lots of screams, grunts and just noises in general*
Mark: Oh my gaud
*Loud Dramatic music ensues*
Ryan: Okay
Mark I'm Good.  Matthias: Oh you gotta go this way now.
*Dramatic music, laughter and Markimoo's pained noises.*
Mark: Oh god XD
*More Dramatic music, laughter and Markimoo's pained noises.*
Markiplier: Thats so hard!
Markiplier: Cause i was like flinching to get out of the water balloons
Markiplier: And i got smacked in the face
Markiplier: It moved the goggles
Markiplier: And i had to like.... [eat them in order to become one with the universe, I failed]  and I had to move up and down [Like a kangaroo]
Matthias: Good luck Bryan!
Matthias: Team Edge, am i right?
J-Fred: GO BRYAN GO!
Bryan: Oh right in the goggles!
Matthias: Keep going!
Matthias: What?
J-Fred: There's water on it!
Matthias: Come on dude!
Matthias: Come on!
Bryan: That is so much harder on when it's wet!
Markiplier: So it's gonna be more and more challenging
Markiplier: the further this race goes
Markiplier: Because the slide is getting more wet
Markiplier: Which means it's harder to get
Markiplier: traction going up
Matthias: Alright make your way into the butthole
Matthias: Oh what the heck?
Matthias: Dude he's like the best!
Matt: It hurts
Matt: That's way more painful than it looks!
Three, Two, One
Bryan: Nice job!
Matthias: Where did my sock go?
Markiplier: Alright you got this!
Three, Two, One, GO
Put the goggles back on
Ryan: I did it!
Markiplier: It's the fastest time!
Markiplier: Holy crap!
J-Fred: Dude he just went flying down!
J-Fred: Both times!
J-Fred: He came back down and just went BOOM!
Three, Two, One
Matthias: Oh jeez he's just flying dude!
And...Time
I couldn't get back up on that thing
Cuz I didn't have my socks
Markiplier: So that's the new record!
Matthias: Dang!
Markiplier: Alright so that was the one of the balloon castle
Markiplier: dodging drunk challenge!
Markiplier: Our team - LordMinion777 won by 7 seconds
Markiplier: So thank you Team Edge for joining us
Markiplier: And thank you Matt and Ryan
Markiplier: Wow Ryan
Matt: That was impressive
Ryan: Oh thanks guys!
Markiplier: We did another challenge with this bouncy castle over on Team Edge's channel
Markiplier: Check it out in the description
Markiplier: And we had a lot of fun there!
Markiplier: Will see who wins
Markiplier: And as always will see you in the next video!
Markiplier: Bye bye!